reflecting on the sweep of where we are
now as a nation
you know what what what would you be
saying at this time to you know all of
us that are carefully listening how do
we you know how do we make success out
of the path we're on and the future we
want to have
food stamps
is to recovers it Duty discover some
common purposes
and to understand what the long range
objectives of this country should be in
some unified way
and then we can apply that confidence we
might develop through this process to
the complete issues that have been
mentioned in in this discussion
I am deeply worried about the nature of
our domestic debate at the moment and
that then makes everything we do a sort
of a technical project in relation to
its specific
if you but the specific issues if Ray
and I are right
are a reflection of a process that is
going on and we have to learn to
understand to think about these
processes
and how to manage them I would say that
they are preeminent death then we will
I'm pretty confident about the
technological problems because we're
good at that
if we know the purposes
but we cannot do it simply serving daily
problems we have to learn to think in a
historical terms
Ray you're the author of this remarkable
book I'm going to give you the the last
word I'm going to say final conclusion
thank yous but I give you the last word
here
um once again Henry and I um see this I
I like um
uh the capacity
um that we have we we've never had in
the world the highest per capita income
that we have the most wealth the wealth
most technology
um it's really
um that we have the capacity if we deal
with these things correctly uh to avoid
that and have go on and have a better
living standard than ever
um it's all within us
um I like
um Henry's uh word about worry he and I
have talked about this one of the
reasons we wanted to do this is because
um I believe and he believes that if we
worry we don't have to worry and if you
don't worry you need to worry because if
you worry about these things then you'll
will pay attention to eliminate or
reduce the risks of the things you're
worrying about but if we don't worry
about these things then we are not going
to do that so the worrying about the war
the worrying about these types of
conflicts I think can be a motivation to
move on and to dig deep within ourselves
to be uh the best people we can in terms
of dealing together with uh what is our
common interest